let me show you how it works i could
just punch this into my calculator
okay but number one that will take me
longer to type number two
that approach is going to fail me when i
don't have
numbers in here when i have variables
okay so my calculator can't be
my like you know my the way i'm going to
go all the time
it's going to be very very usefu useless
later on to rely on them
so here's what i'm going to do 10
factorial by definition
is 10 by 9 by 8
etc okay now i could write that whole
thing out but i don't need to write all
of it to be useful
i can write 10 by 9 by now instead of
writing
8 times 6 5 4 1 i'm just going to write
8 factorial
okay because that's what 10 factorial is
and the reason why i do that of course
is because 8 factorial is on the
denominator
okay see that yeah so i can just go
bam i i don't even need to multiply i
can just go five by nine
look ma no calculator okay so that's
good
and also when we go to algebra is pretty
much necessary let's have a look at
you might be able to see it might jump
out at you what this is equal to
okay but even if it does you still need
to actually show well why is that the
case
okay so again i'm pulling i'm going to
fill out a similar trick that i did here
right some textbooks like this one they
call it unrolling a factorial
okay because that factorial is kind of
like this um this twisted up
thing right and you've got all these
numbers these layers that are
multiplying by each other
and you can just kind of take part of it
and like
unwrap it right so i unwrapped the 10
and the 9
out of the 10 factorial so that what was
left
was the eight factorial which can cancel
right so i'm gonna do a similar thing
here except that i've got no numbers
right n factorial i just want to phrase
it in terms that will allow me to cancel
right so the largest term in n factorial
is n what's the next largest term
n minus 1 like nine for instance so
i've got this yes and that's all over
n minus one factorial so you can see
this is just m
right